I listen first of all a fan of both of
your work uh thank you if but there's
going to be people out there who've
never seen anything you've done so if
someone has never seen anything uh
what's the first thing you want them
watching and why right now asteroid City
well besides asteroids it's easy to say
that I guess if
trying to find out about me
sure I would want them to see the first
job I ever did which was a BBC limited
series of Little Women
um and I just poured my heart out and
Joe's one of my favorite characters ever
and
um I I don't know I'm still proud of my
work I did there and I feel like and I
was really young and I guess I feel like
where I started would be a good place to
start uh for me it would be a movie
called death of Stalin
um because it was a chance to be as
ridiculous as I think I am and I if
you've never seen me before you probably
think that I'm a bit serious and that's
that's definitely more My Vibe you've
worked with Wes before you've not worked
with Wes I'm just curious when you find
out that Wes wants to meet with you are
you like is this an episode of punked am
I you know what I mean for me I felt
like that but I it didn't it didn't
happen that way I think the first time
you work with West is really different
than the rest of the times because the
first time I auditioned and it was like
a long scene and it was kind of every
scene I have in this movie really I did
as an audition and sent them in and then
a couple days later I got the call that
I had to go to Spain in the next 24
hours and I was like when I get there
like are they gonna be there like is
this real like what's what am I going to
arrive into
um so it was one of the most exciting
couple days of my life I like rarely go
out and like celebrate having gotten
apart but I went out with all my friends
and we got a drink and went dancing and
I was then I was like and I gotta go to
the airport now like it was just like I
so much joy in my heart one of the
things uh I'm a big Wes Anderson fan and
um people who are going to be watching
this are Big Wes Anderson fans what do
you think would surprise West fans to
learn about working with Wes and making
a Wes Anderson movie what's tricky
because I don't know what they expect
these Wes Anderson fans I don't know how
to think about what might surprise them
maybe like the level of loyalty and
collaboration that he embodies with not
just his cast there are all of these
people these like workers that don't get
these artists that don't get the same
kind of recognition as the actors do
when a movie comes out that aren't doing
these interviews or sitting here but who
have everything to do with what made
this film Amazing
um from like the head grip that does all
of Wes's movies to the props work to the
like to the cost of Millennia like it's
just Wes has built this team around him
that worked to execute his vision of
course but in and of themselves are
these extraordinary artists
um and you really feel the weight of
their significance and the respect that
Wes has for them every day on set one of
the things is I would imagine on set Wes
this is he's such an artist and he knows
what he wants before he steps on set he
the way he moves camera the way he has
actors just everything seems so out of
his brain so what is it like as an actor
where you're trying to you know do
specific movements to make Wes's Vision
come true versus maybe finding it in the
moment you know what I mean because it's
a different kind of acting or different
kind of performance I would imagine well
we had a good example of the opposite of
that which may or may not surprise
um you and your viewers which is that
our sort of musical number the interlude
all it said at the end of that was then
they dance that was it so that whole
kind of exuberant sort of throw your hat
in the air and grab each other and whirl
off and the kids go that was just
happened on the spot there was no
choreography there was no marks to hit
there was no kind of specificity other
than the joy of the beginning of a new
maybe love affair that we don't know
whether it's ever developed but I
believe what he said on the day was well
why don't you just Shuffle down towards
the camera a little bit at a certain
point and then shuffle your way away and
then I see the kids and we said oh oh
okay and that was it that actually leads
to my next question some directors give
a lot of Direction and are very specific
some will just give a few words
obviously you guys know this what is
West like on set and does he ever like
raise his temperature in terms of when
he's not getting something he wants what
is he like behind the scenes never seen
him raise his temperature I have a short
story of what it looks like when I think
his temperature does raise which is not
raised he he called me
how do I get everyone to stop using
their phones
and I was like oh you're Furious and
that's what Furious looks like on you
like his temperature doesn't raise he
doesn't act out he's never cruel yeah um
no he has Limitless patience as well so
um you know let's say you forget the
line or you don't hit the mark or
something he gets he's excited to get to
do it again and when he's gotten what he
wants we do it again as Wes would say
for the pleasure he would always say one
more for the pleasure and it reminds you
that making movies is a joyful thing you
know we're not digging ditches here and
so if we've done it 40 or 50 times and
it's been very tiring but we've got it
there's a feeling of ah so let's just do
it again and live in that moment for a
second one of the things about less is
when you look at the poster you can see
there's a few actors that like to work
with him a few names what is it actually
like working with such an All-Star cast
and I know like it's so easy to be like
oh it's a great experience but this is a
really murderer's lineup of people yeah
it is and we you know sequester together
to while we're making the film it was
covid so we made a bubble
um so we got to know each other very
well off screen because as you if you
see in the film The storylines threaded
and you know we don't all interact on
camera but we definitely all interacted
uh off camera
um and there's no hierarchy no so
there's not this feeling where it's like
oh this person's walking on and there's
their security team and like and their
box and their bubble and that dressing
room don't knock on his like it's none
of that it's really like he loves
working with these big stars but he kind
of cuts down all the star frill around
it so it really just feels like being at
like a really great summer camp
um with wonderful smart people who are
really excited to have that kind of
hierarchy list acting experience I mean
Jason insists on sitting at the head of
the table every night every night his
ego's huge he won't look you in the eye
it's very strange no other than that
everyone's pretty egletarian yeah right
I mean Jason has done a lot of Wes
Anderson and he wears that as a bank
yeah he's like I am the king also he's
spotting the new spider verse movie he
is a diva like he's a huge Diva he does
need to be taken down a peg or two so if
you see him do you see him let him know
remind him of the films he's been in
that didn't work so yeah
on that note I need to go I'm just going
to say I am also looking forward to a
Ronald Dahl Wes Anderson movie and
something called you know Bradley Cooper
film that might be coming out later this
year perhaps and I'm looking forward to
those things too